i feel even like i'm about to be put in
the electric chair
an internal investigation the show shut
down
yes et has learned the talk is taking a
hiatus for a couple days
while the review of matters from last
week continues
if anyone should be crying it should be
me
it is not the exact words
of racism it's the implication
and the reaction to it and proof that
sharon is doubling down
three days after former talk co-host
holly robinson pete claimed sharon had
her fired in 2011 for being quote
to ghetto look okay like it's like this
sharon fired back telling variety i
cannot have anyone fired and that's not
a term i use
i don't speak like that and then sharon
shared a private email pete sent her a
month after being let go
in it holly seems to say julie chen was
the reason for it all citing a racist
comment
and spreading venomous lies so what's
next for the embattled talk show
the ladies plan to return to work on
wednesday despite sharon's claims of
being
blindsided by the whole situation
[Music]